僕ちゃんっ！ご飯を食べるときはっ！
ほぼっ！ほぼ大抵！
コンビニです（ﾄﾞﾔｱ）
ほぼ大抵コンビニなんですけども
なんかあるじゃないですか
コンビニに大抵売ってるような物
例えばおにぎりとか肉まん
最近僕がコンビニでハマっているのがっ！
Yeah HOT DOG
Repeat after me
HOT DOG
No×５
Repeat after me
フェットビック（？）
ていうわけで今回こちらに有名なコンビニのホットドッグを５種類集めました
このスタジオ電子レンジがないんすよ！
ﾁｪｯ!
電子レンジが無いので家に帰って速攻温めて今帰ってきたところなんで
ﾊｧﾊｧﾊｧﾊｧﾊｧ…
ちょっと疲れてます
まずはこちら
もう王道と言っても過言ではないでしょう
セブンイレブンのホットドッグ
続いてこちら
ローソンのホットドッグです
パリッとジューシーなホットドッグていうことで
ちょっとパリパリっとしてるのを売りにしてるのかな？
続いてこちら
ファミリーマートのホットドッグです
あ～これもパリっとジューシーなくくりなんだ
うわ～これ
セブン、パリっとジューシーって書いてないんですけども
ローソンパリっとジューシーって書いてあるんで
これファミマとローソンでパリっとジューシーバトルが行われる気がしますね
続いてこちら
ミニストップのホットドッグ
これなんか書いてあるかな？
あっ！
上手いことかわしてます
これがちょっと微妙なんですけども
ヤマザキのホットドッグなんですけど
無かったんでチーズのホットドッグになってしまいました
今回の戦いでもうチーズ乗ってる時点で反則なんです
まぁ一応参考として一応チーズのホットドッグも入れておきます
まぁほぼズルですね
あのなんかホントねホットドッグってね旨いんですよ
ちょっと解説させてください
そもそもホットドッグどこで生まれたかというとアメリカなんですよ
まぁ簡単に言うとソーセージを細いパンで挟んであるものをホットドッグと言います
そしてアメリカにはなんとアメリカ評議会ナショナルホットドッグソーセージ評議会というチームがありまして
その人たちによるとホットドッグはサンドイッチとは全く別で
ホットドッグはホットドッグとし
一つの食品であるということが言われております
味付けはマスタードが基本でございます
好みに応じてトマトケチャップをかけたり
玉ねぎをかけたり
細かく刻んだピクルスを乗せられたりします
他にもチリミートをかけたチリドッグ
溶かしたチェダーチーズをかけたもの
トマトなどの野菜を挟んだシカゴドッグ
サラサをかけたサラサドッグなど
さまざまなバリエーションがホットドッグにはあります
ただのパンの食べ方の一種じゃんと思う方もいると思うんですけど
消してそういうわけではなく
まぁ歴史的なしっかりとした食品の一つという
認定がされております
まぁアメリカでホットドッグが生まれたと言いましたんですけども
結局スタートを辿るとドイツの移民の方…
ホントに最近めちゃくちゃ食ってるんですよホットドッグ
で、そもそもなんでホットドッグが好きになったっていうと
まぁちょっと最近肌寒くなってきたので
肉まんとかあったかい物を食べようかなと思ったんですけども
ここはせっかくならホットドッグを食べてみようと思って買ってみたのがキッカケで
そしてホットドッグを食べてみるととてもおいしくて
気づいたらホットドッグの虜…
いやもう早速一個づつ開けていきましょうか
やべぇ、早く食べないと
ｻﾒﾁｬｳｯ!!!
えっとカロリーだけの話を先にさせていただきましょう
カロリーで言うとセブンのほうが297Kcal
ローソンが279Kcal
え～　ファミマが290Kcal
ミニストップが287Kcal
ヤマザキのチーズホットドッグが318Kcal
まぁこれはチーズかかってるので仕方ないですね
ローソンのホットドッグが一番カロリーが低いです
さぁちょっと　あのホントに
数あるコンビニの中でホットドッグを買うときに
どれを食えば一番良いのかっていうのはとても気になる所なんですよ
僕はちょっと本気でね、正しく平等で
しっかりと判断していきたいと思います
アメリカの食いもんなんて
見た目なんてあんまり気にしねぇんだよ
そう、ただただ　旨ければいい
俺たちのココに響くソウルフードなら
それでいいじゃん！
いただきますっ
（ﾊﾟｸｯ）
ん～！旨い！
ﾝﾝﾝﾝ!!　うまま～！
（ﾊﾟｸｯ）
ｳﾓｫｫｫｫ　ｳﾏｧｧｧｧ
ｳﾓｫｫｫｫｫ
ｳﾓｫｫｫｫｫ!!!
ﾊﾞｰｲ!!
（エンディング）
って行きたいところなんですけども
しっかり評価していきましょう今回は
全然ホットドッグ素人なんですけども
ホットドッグのポイントを3点に絞りたいと思います
まずはパン
そして中のソーセージ
あとはマスタード、ケチャップ
まぁソースですね
この３つで評価していきたいと思います
じゃあちょっとごめんなさい
もうちょっと食べて評価させてください
(ﾓｸﾞﾓｸﾞ…）
お腹一杯になっちゃった…(´・ω・｀)
ヤバい結構判断しようと思って食いまくったら
お腹が一杯になって来ちゃった…
大体の点数をつけてみたのでちょっと順番に見ていきましょう
まずはっ！
セブンッ！
え～セブン、ズバリ言いましょう
パンの点数３
ソーセージが５
ソースが３
でございました
あの美味しいんですよ
他のホットドッグとセブンイレブンのホットドッグが
大きく違うところが一点ありました
それは何かというとパンなんですよ
なんかホットドッグのパンのそのソーセージが入る切れ目の部分で
ちょびっとね、この生地が違っていまして
で、他のやつもやっぱ違うんですけども
そんなに差は無いんですけどもセブンはもう
バッチリ違いますからね
ここがすごいバッチリ違うんですけども
なんかそれのせいか知らないんですけども
パン自体がちょっと硬くて
パサパサしてるんですよね
えっわかんないですよ
僕は本場のアメリカンじゃないんで
分かんないんですけども
ひょっとしたらアメリカだと
アメリカだとですよ！
アメリカだと！
パンの周りはこのカサカサしてて正解なのかも知れない
これが本場のホットドッグ
ここは！
日本ですっ！
僕個人的にはちょっと
このパサパサしたパンがあんまり受けなかったので
3点にさせて頂きました
めちゃくちゃ美味しいです　でも！
ローソンもなぁ中々いい線行ってると思うんですけども
パンが4点
ソーセージが5点
ソースが3点
ぐらいかなぁっていう感じですね
で、ソーセージもジューシー
噛むと肉汁がちょっとドロドロ落ちてくるぐらい
とても美味しい
ﾀﾀﾞｯ!!
ソースがもう一歩だったっ！
いや分かんない　俺の個人の意見だからね
マスタードがすごいなんかあらびきすぎる
むしろなんか何このツブツブがメインみたいな状態になってて
ちょっと辛すぎるかなっていう印象が僕の中にはあったんですけど
皆さんはどうか分かりません
僕は甘党なのでっ　甘党の意見の一つとして
ちょっとマスタードがツブツブすぎて
あ↑ら↓びきすぎてる感じ
発音がおかしかったなｗ
あらびきすぎてる感じがしました
ﾌｩ…　ﾌｩ…
次…
ファミリーマートです…
はい　え～ファミリーマートのホットドッグ
ズバリ！
パン５！ソーセージ３！ソース５！
ってイメージです僕の中では
ただこれ多分ね俺だけな気がするんだよなぁ
甘い物が好きな人は
ファミマがすごいオススメな気がします
なんかこう日本に対応させてる感じがすごい気がします
で、ソーセージもねぇ　パリパリしてて美味しいんですけども
ちょっと細くて物足りないかなっていうイメージが
僕の中ではありました
ソースが素晴らしい！
あらびきマスタードではなく、あの子供たちが好きな
あの普通の黄色いあのマスタードを使っているので
ちょっと甘くて、個人的にファミマのやつが
一番食べやすいかなっていうかちょっと甘い感じで
気軽に食べれたかなって思います
(ﾓｸﾞﾓｸﾞ…）
はい4つ目はミニストップのホットドッグです
すいません公正な判断が出来ねぇかもしれません
お腹が一杯です
あぁ～うんうんうん
パン４　ソーセージ４　ソース４
ヤバいなんかもう味が
味が分らんけど取りあえず多分
お腹空いてるときだと
美味しそうだなぁ…
うん。なんかソーセージが美味しい
至ってシンプルな…ホットドッグです…
ﾊｧｧｧ…
じゃー最後　ヤマザキのホットドッグ食べていきたいと思います
いただきます…
(ﾓｸﾞ…）
これは…
ホットドッグではなぁい！
評価出来ないっ！！
ホットドッグっていうのは
ホットドッグっていうのはなぁ！
パンに、細いソーセージを挟んで
ケチャップ、マスタード！
このコンビネーションで初めてホットドッグって言うんだよぉ！
だからこの！
チーズが入ってるホットドッグはホットドッグでは無い！
よって、
失格っ！！
(ﾓｸﾞﾓｸﾞ…）
まぁ今回食べてみて僕が一番
美味しいと思ったホットドッグはっ！
ごめん…
お腹いっぱいでよくわかんねぇや
（エンディング）
まぁ個人的には
…ファミマかなぁ
ファミマがすごい美味しかったと思います
個人的には
良かったら皆さんも食べてみて下さい…
ｵｪｪ